once Wes Craven had designed Freddy
Krueger he had to dress him but this
also presented a unique problem for a
shape-shifting nightmare Spirit the
filmmaker had to come up with something
so recognizable that viewers would
understand instantly they were looking
at Freddy even when he wasn't in his
standard form Craven seemed to
instinctively understand something
branding experts harp on about today
that the right color scheme can create a
look so recognizable that audiences
automatically associated with the thing
they're meant to speaking to C
fantastique Craven said he wanted
Freddy's costume to be obvious no matter
what form he shape-shifted into he was
inspired by the DC Comics hero Plastic
Man as the Director put it he used to
change shape but you could always tell
it was him so I wanted Freddy to be a
shape shifter that could be recognized
from his colors to find the right
palette the filmmaker didn't have to
look much further than his coffee table
Craven read a 1982 issue of Scientific
American that reported that to the human
retina the most contrasting colors are
red in green